So bc was an example of
a line oriented program, but
not every program we use in
the terminal works this way.
You've already seen one
program that doesn't.
The man program, for reading the manual
takes up a full terminal screen.
It's actually use another program called
less that knows how to display text
one page at a time.
So when you press Q to stop
looking at a manual page.
You're actually using a command
that less understands.
And you can use less to display any
file you like not just man pages.
Let's try using less
on a long text file.
Remember to use tab completion when
entering a long filename like this one.
Scrolling up and down with arrow keys
works the same way as it did before, and
man you can also scroll down a page
at a time by using the D key or
by hitting the Space Bar.
You can scroll up one page
at a time wit a U key.
If you want to skip to very
last line of the file,
you can use the right angle bracket for
that.
To get back up to the first line
use the left angle bracket.
You can go to a particular line
by typing its line number and
hitting Enter.
This is particularly useful when working
with source code where you know the line
numbers of important lines.
It's also useful when you decide to
quickly move to the middle of a file.
Less also has built-in search.
Type slash and then the string
you'd like to search for.
Press Enter or
return to execute the search.
You can find the next occurrence
of the search term by pressing n.
To go back to the previous occurrence,
use capital N.
Search terms are case sensitive.
Searching for otter with a lower case o,
won't find any capital O otters.
If you're familiar with regular
expressions you can use them here,
unless the search is actually looking
for lines that match your pattern.
If you don't know regular expressions,
you can still use lesson search
capability, but you should be
careful and only search for
patterns consisting of numbers and
letters.
The regular expression library will
interpret other characters in ways you
might not expect.